here with reaction Ohio Senator J.D
Vance yes
[Applause]
be outraged and very angry tonight
um and I'm not trusting any of those
politicians that are saying oh drink the
water watch me drink the water they're
probably drinking Evian so you know I
don't trust why no concern from the
president why he went to Ukraine why
can't he go to East Palestine
look Charlotte I think this is all about
friends versus enemies and he does not
see the people of East Palestine as
friends because not enough of them voted
for him and so he's not paying attention
to what's going on on the ground there
Sean it's important to note this is not
just a lack of leadership from the
president it's a lack of action from his
administration as I sit here speaking
Sean there are mounds of toxic dirt
sitting in East Palestine that Norfolk
Southern has dug out of the ground that
they cannot get to the licensed
facilities the dispose of hazardous
chemicals because the Biden
administration's EPA is not letting them
I would repeat that because Biden's EPA
is not doing its job East Palestine has
toxic chemicals mounds of toxic
chemicals just sitting on the ground
what happens if it rains and this stuff
seeps back into the ground it's a total
disaster and at every level whether it's
Norfolk Southern the EPA or somebody
else it feels like the people of East
Palestine are being failed by everybody
it's a total disgrace let me ask you how
we can independently corroborate and and
inform the people of East Palestine that
things are safe uh because everything
that our government pretty much told us
about covet ended up being dead wrong so
I don't have any faith hope or trust in
the federal government when it comes to
my health or the anybody in this
audience's health or the people of these
Palestine is there going to be an
independent group with No Agenda that
can tell them definitively the air is
safe to breathe the water is safe to
drink
well the first thing Sean is if you want
to give people confidence that things
are safe you've got to get the toxic
chemicals out of there in the first
place nobody is going to believe that
East Palestine is safe when you still
haven't cleaned up the original chemical
disaster site six weeks later that
hasn't happened now after that happens
you point out a very important Point
here which is how do we trust the
testing that happens and I I think our
office is actually supporting and
working with a number of organizations
that are doing independent testing on
the ground we're asking other people to
get involved so that we can do some
long-term testing of the residents
people have been seeking personal health
testing and some of them have been
unable to get it so we've got to just
offer everybody everything that they
need here to ensure that their health is
on the right track but the very first
step is we've got to clean up the
community first and foremost we've got
to start there until you do that nobody
is going to have confidence in East
Palestine safety well the EPA got it
wrong too on on Ground Zero after 9 11
and I remember reporting from Ground
Zero at that time and for weeks it was
nothing but it was like snowing dust and
dirt and debris but the EPA at the time
said oh no the air is safe and so many
people you know ended up with with lung
issues as a result even to this day
people are still dying as a result of
being lied to by the government and you
know and one of the people of East
Palestine do in terms of their home
values uh excuse me but as much as I
love Ohio and you do know I love Ohio I
love you I love Jim Jordan I love Billy
Cunningham a great talk show host who's
out there but you know what is anyone
going to want to buy a house and he's
Palestine because I'm not interested
uh it's a big issue Sean the long-term
cleanup and the long-term you know
Redevelopment of East Palestine is going
to be something we have to work on uh
you're exactly right home values have
already fallen through the floor you've
got a lot of local farmers saying nobody
wants to buy my product a local a lot of
local small businesses where nobody's
coming in because people aren't
traveling to East Palestine right now
the economic Devastation of the long
term is something is we're going to have
to deal with and it's why we can't leave
people behind there is a terror in East
Palestine Sean I know you're not going
to let up I know others won't let up I
certainly won't but there is a terror
that they're going to be left behind and
ignored that by demonstration certainly
is not giving them any confidence so
we've got to stay on top of them we've
got to ensure like you said the
independent testing not just the
Government testing and we've got to make
sure that the people of East Palestine
know there are people and we're not
going to forget about them listen I
don't really give a rip if Joe Biden
comes he's a day late and a dollar short
but I do believe that that we Americans
before we take care of every other
country that we should be taking care of
Americans first
Ohio and that means helping them on
their home values and ensuring they have
clean air and clean water and it's that
simple before we spend any other money
period uh will that happen
uh I hope it will happen Sean I'm going
to fight every single step of the way to
make sure that it does happen but you're
exactly right if America First means
anything it means taking care of the
people of East Palestine before people
in other places it means of course
locking down our border and it means
ensuring that communities that are
devastated through no fault of their own
are able to get back on their feet right
now our priority needs to be is
Palestine as a country whatever Joe
Biden says that's exactly what we're
going to keep on working on and make
sure it happens the thing we cannot stop
doing Sean is talking about this
community the failure to clean it up the
failure to provide support we cannot
leave these people behind and by the way
I'll add one thing pothole Pete needs to
go he needs to be fired all right JD
Vance thank you for being with us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else